[Musica]
[Applauso]
era il 5 giugno 94 anno che oggi va alla
grande e lo speaker delle finali
nazionali a un certo punto dice e adesso
c'è un premio speciale per uno di voi
perché c'era la parte maschile e una di
voi e questo premio speciale con la
musica di we are the champions in
sottofondo va a chiara biasi ok chiesa
di un attimo di panico io mi sono girata
in cerca di capire chi fosse questa
chiara e poi i miei compagni mi hanno
spinto non eravamo arrivati in finale
solamente quinte quindi è stato un
premio anche inaspettato uno dei giorni
ovviamente più più felici della mia vita
ne sono arrivati altri poi grazie alla
pallavolo selezioni varie il 5 maggio la
chiamata in nazionale però quel giorno
lì aveva oltre alla felicità
aveva anche un sapore malinconico perché
i miei genitori non c'erano da pochi
mesi papa aveva cominciato la dialisi da
pochi mesi la mia famiglia era entrata
in questo in questo nuovo mondo che si
chiama insufficienza renale cronica
così io l'ho conosciuta attraverso di
lui ho cominciato a familiarizzare con
termini come emodialisi creatinina che è
l'indice di misura della funzionalità
renale potassio il terrore del potassio
contermini con termini medici per per
aiutare un po il papa sono trascorsi due
o tre anni
io continuavo continuavo a giocare
andavo a scuola facevo il liceo finché
finché un giorno c'è stato un incontro
inaspettato
un incontro che mi ha letteralmente
lasciato senza fiato
mi ha fatto tremare le gambe e mi ha
accettato la vista non mi ero innamorata
ero semplicemente semplicemente sono
praticamente quasi svenuta da lì sono
cominciate una serie di controlli ma già
dalla prima dalla primissima busta
aperta e la mia famiglia abbiamo capito
il valore della mia creatinina era 77
volte più del normale
abbiamo capito subito tutto consultati
medici nel giro di due mesi mi sono
ritrovata dal fare quattro allenamenti a
settimana a fare tre sedute di dialisi
in ospedale a settimana da quattro ore
da poter bere mangiare quello che volevo
ad aver paura di mangiare un
cioccolatino in più proprio per paura
del potassio bear per non morire la
diagnosi possa riassumerla così in
quattro parole e dolore dolore fisico
perché gli aghi che usano per portare il
tuo sangue in questa macchina che che fa
il lavoro di quel che dovrebbero fare i
nostri reni sono sono belli grossi e
fanno male la dialisi ti porta ad avere
paura paura quotidiana per quello che vi
dicevo prima la dialisi ti porta ad
avere 7 il tuo corpo a chiede di
purificarsi perché le tossine si stanno
intasando ma tu non puoi vere perché
ovviamente quello funzionando i reni e
liquidi non vengono espulsi la dialisi è
avere lato quotidianità
rivoluzionata non c'è più tre pomeriggi
a settimana per studiare ti deve
ingegnare io studiavo la mattina presto
alle 3 alle 4 perché perché dopo dialisi
sei sfinito
a me il primario l'aveva descritta così
è come se tu chiara facessi ogni volta
una partita di 57 arriva sì sempre il
tie break ma non ci sono le altre
compagne
questo deve sopportare il tuo corpo
quando fai dialisi la dialisi ti fa
scoprire vulnerabile e a 16 17 anni
invece ai tutt'altro in mente no ti
pensi onnipotente tutte le strade e la
tua vita sono aperte puoi scegliere
qualunque cosa e invece li scopri che
che non sei così che non sai perfetto
che non funzioni perfettamente la
dialisi ti porta a rinunciare alla pizza
con gli amici perché poi sai di avere
sete e ti chiudi un po in casa la
diagnosi ti porta a vedere lo sguardo
quando delle altre persone quando
guardano il tuo braccio che essendo
bucato può alludere a qualsiasi altra
cosa la dialisi ti portavi alla libertà
non sei più a gestire tu il tuo tempo ma
sono i ritmi dell'emodialisi a darti il
tempo questo è il tuo tempo libero non
ne hai altro
ho fatto due anni di dialisi non sono
guarita poi dal insufficienza renale
cronica non si guarisce però si può
curare con l'emodialisi si sopravvive
c'è un'altra cosa che ti fa vivere
invece ed è il trapianto ho fatto tutti
gli esami per entrare in questa lista
trapianto erano anche piuttosto invasivi
per l'età e sono entrata in lista non
ero tanto convinta
avevo l'esempio del papa davanti e
questa è stata la mia fortuna sono
entrata in lista
ho aspettato e trascorsi sono trascorsi
la quarta e la quinta liceo e il 5
maggio mese e mezzo prima della maturità
è arrivata una chiamata chiara domani ti
aspettiamo
ma come io devo fare l'esame di maturità
io non ci fosse venire ovviamente
ovviamente i miei genitori e i medici mi
hanno detto no non hai capito
questa è la tua occasione il 5 maggio ho
fatto il trapianto dopo 20 giorni sono
uscita e parlando con i professori mano
ha detto beh farà gli esami a settembre
no no no no no no no io voglio avere
questa estate libera non voglio più
non voglio avere condizionamenti
assolutamente e e un po scusarsi
[Musica]
i sentimenti quella notte felicità
felicità per quello che mi aspettava
sapevo che sarei stata liberata da tante
cose
la tristezza per chi mi aveva donato
quella parte quel bene
pensavo alla sua famiglia e vedevo la
mia da un lato una famiglia che piangeva
dall'altra una famiglia che sperava
dall'alto da un lato la morte e
dall'altra una vita nuova che e si
affacciava ecco il trapianto è andato
bene mi sono iscritta all'università
fuori sede avevo proprio bisogno di
riprendere come dire riprendere ma
estesa di di fare quello che che volevo
e sono stati anni belli anni belli in
questi anni ovviamente poi così qualche
ragazzo diceva si avvicinava e io lo
ritenevo tutti a distanza non ne volevo
sapere
pensavo che nessuno avrebbe mai potuto
stare insieme ad una malata cronica e
invece sono stata smentita è arrivata
una persona ha aspettato due anni per il
primo appuntamento è però ha fatto
breccia è un inguaribile ottimista ha
una pazienza fortissima
siamo stati fidanzati sette anni in
perché perché quando le cose si facevano
serie ovviamente lui sempre quel primo
ha cominciato a parlarmi di famiglia di
matrimonio gli ho detto no no no no io
sono troppo imprevedibile
la mia vita è troppo imprevedibile che
queste cose non si può però in quei
sette anni c'è stato anche un momento in
cui farmaci antirigetto
mi hanno messo a dura prova e lui è
rimasto lì allora dopo quella quella
fase molto brutta quegli anni molto
brutti in cui poi ho anche perso papà ho
detto ok mi figlio mi fido di te mi fido
di quello che sento nel cuore
sposiamoci ma sappi che è molto
difficile per me avere una famiglia e
per la vedo una famiglia intendo dei
bambini lui inguaribile ottimista mi
diceva sempre guarda io sono fiducioso
vabbè ok tu sei fiducioso io bambino
però ci siamo sposati le gravidanze e è
possibile per una trapiantata per una
che è in dialisi no o almeno è molto
molto molto molto molto molto molto raro
ci siamo sposati
la dottoressa immaginando il percorso e
mi conosceva e la voglia di famiglia mi
ha detto chiara dobbiamo anche se volete
avere un bambino dobbiamo anche
programmarci ecco è stata l'unica volta
in cui mi sono ribellata e ha detto no
questo no
almeno questo lasciatemelo va beh fatto
sta che un mese da un po il viaggio di
nozze sono ricoverata per l'ennesima
dell'ennesima a piero nefrite infezione
al rene che quell'anno mi stava
veramente mi stava veramente assillando
è un medico mi ha fatto ma un test di
gravidanza mia insaputa è risultato
positivo
la scena è stata paradossale perché io
piangevo e
mirko entra mi vede piangere il dubbio
era il re di non funziona più non ho
detto qui qui c'è un bambino
esatto abbiamo pianto un po tutti
insomma c'è stato uno scambio
incredibile fra l'ospedale di conegliano
e il centro trapianti di treviso perché
perché non era mai successo io ero
felice i medici mi hanno detto non
sappiamo se riesci a portarlo a termine
e però io ero felice lo stesso è detto
affinché va lo portiamo avanti è andata
bene to be sì
[Musica]
questa
questo è emanuele è nato piccolissimo è
dato di un chilo perché il mio rene
verso il sesto mese ha cominciato a dare
segni di cedimento
adesso a 6 anni ed è un vulcano
dopo un po il mio rene si è ripreso la
mia con emanuele insomma non è non è
stato facile riprendersi comunque anche
da una gravidanza a rischio una sorpresa
un'altra sorpresa della vita dopo un
anno e mezzo scopre di aspettare un
altro bambino panico panico perché nello
stesso praticamente simultaneamente
scopro anche di aver preso il
citomegalovirus il sito malagò al virus
può dare essere mortale per noi
trapiantati e poi può dare delle
disabilità ai bimbi anche qui decisioni
importanti la decisione però l'avevo
presa il mio percorso mi ha fatto
decidere
avevo lavorato con dei bimbi con
disabilità e in quel momento mi sono
venute in mente le mamme di questi
bambini che mai e poi mai avrebbero
rinunciato a loro e io e io mi sono
fidata di quello che sentivo il mio
fegato era andato un po un po in pani
questo sono stati momenti un po così
però è arrivato francesco
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che ha festeggiato cinque anni la
settimana scorsa
ecco dopo francesco è la reazione che
abbia avuto i miei medici e quando anche
perché un lavoro non è immenso per loro
e per la patologia neonatale che li ha
seguiti il mio rene ha cominciato a dare
segni di cedimento
la mia dottoressa mi ha detto chiara
forse un anno forse un anno e mezzo non
di più cosa dici se facciamo un
trapianto da vivente cosa un trapianto
da vivente no non posso accettare di
veder soffrire i miei parenti oi miei
amici o chi o chi mi vuole donare e e
lei mi ha detto ma secondo te sono più
felice vederti in salute oppure che stai
mario ed i e ii mirko che me l'aveva
sempre detto è anche da fidanzati quando
ieri dicevo ma io posso tornare in
dialisi e fa ma che problema c'e ti do
youn renée ok
beh il 26 agosto 2016
c'è un pezzettino di mio marito dentro
di me
[Musica]
e
e lui prima di entrare in sala
operatoria dei tull chirurgo
prendete il rene migliore mi raccomando
ecco io racconto ai miei bambini questa
storia ogni tanto è per bambini
ovviamente e di racconto di vico meglio
il papa ne abbiamo dato la vita come il
buon dio li abbia dato la vita come i
medici che mi hanno seguito gli abbiano
dato la vita
ma la loro vita parte da lontano da chi
dal chirurgo che ha trovato il modo di
innestare i vasi sanguigni da chi
dall'immunologo che ha scoperto perché
perché dopo poco tempo e gli organi
trapiantati vivevano rigettati io sono
fortunata tanto perché nella mia vita ho
ricevuto tanto e adesso spero con questa
salute di potere in qualche modo
restituire quanto ricevuto